en el vídeo anterior vimos la formación
de la unión en ola pto en este vídeo y
en el siguiente
veremos con más detalle la formación de
aniones en o lado y que base podemos
usar por ejemplo aquí la base que
tenemos es una unión es óxido que lo
podemos obtener pellet óxido de sodio
enea más o menos entonces funcionará
como base y tomará un protón de nuestro
aldehído acetona si esto fuera un
aldehído entonces tendríamos
acetaldehído el carbono alfa es este
carbono que se encuentra junto al
carbono en el carbón y lo y tenemos tres
protones alfa pero sólo dibujaré uno así
que nuestra base toma este protón
dejando estos electrones en nuestro
carbón
dibujemos el avión enola toque se forma
aquí tenemos el carbón y lo y tenemos un
par de electrones en este carbono
entonces estos electrones en rosa se
movieron hacia este carbono para formar
nuestro carbón y podemos dibujar una
estructura de resonancia estos
electrones se moverán hacia acá para
formar un doble enlace empujando a estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno
entonces nos queda una estructura de
resonancia donde la carga negativa ahora
se encuentra en el oxígeno y tenemos un
doble enlace del lado derecho
estos electrones en rosa se movieron
para formar nuestro doble enlace y estos
electrones se movieron al oxígeno para
formar el oxidación
este es nuestro año en ola pto aquí
tenemos la estructura del carbón y esta
es la del oxxean jon así que nuestra
base nos ayuda a formar el año en o lato
y una vez que protejamos nuestro stock
sido formaremos etanol entonces en esta
reacción también formamos etanol
estamos en equilibrio entre nuestro
aldehído y nuestra unión y no la pto
pero si queremos saber hacia dónde se
favorece la reacción necesitamos conocer
algunos valores de pk
el valor pk a para este aldehído es de
aproximadamente 17 y para etanol es de
aproximadamente 16 entonces usemos estas
ecuaciones que tenemos abajo necesitamos
conocer el valor pk de equilibrio a
partir de los valores de pk
de los ácidos entonces el ácido de la
izquierda corresponde a nuestro aldehído
y supe que a es de 17 y el pk
del lado derecho es 16 que corresponde
al etanol entonces 17 menos 16 es igual
a 1
y para conocer la constante de
equilibrio
simplemente calculamos 10 elevado a
menos el pk de equilibrio que sería 10 a
la menos uno es igual a punto uno que
obviamente es menor a uno así que el
equilibrio favorece a los reactivos
es decir el equilibrio tiende hacia la
derecha favoreciendo la formación de
nuestro aldehído entonces si elegimos
set óxido de sodio como base al estar en
equilibrio tendremos la presencia tanto
de nuestro aldehído como de nuestro
avión enola pto otra forma de poder
averiguar hacia qué lado tiende el
equilibrio es identificar el ácido más
débil
tenemos un ácido con un pequeã de 17 y
otro de 16 / menor sea el p
a más ácido será así que el etanol es
más ácido que nuestro aldehído y por lo
tanto el equilibrio favorece la
formación del ácido más débil es decir
que tiende hacia la formación del
aldehído pero qué pasa si queremos
obtener nuestro año y no la toco
completamente bueno lo que podemos hacer
es agregar una neón y bruno como base
aquí tenemos nuestro acetaldehído y esta
base la podemos obtener a partir de algo
como hidruro de sodio tiene a más h - o
hidruro de potasio k más h menos y una
vez que identificamos nuestro carbono
alfa aquí tenemos 3 protones alfa pero
sólo dibujaré 1 así que nuestro hidruro
puede funcionar como base y tomará este
protón
cuando estos electrones en el carbono
dibujemos el avión enola pto tenemos
nuestro carbón hilo y un par de
electrones libres en este carbono lo que
le da una carga formal negativa entonces
los electrones en rosa se movieron a
este carbono para formar el carbón y
para ahorrar tiempo no dibujar el
oxidación así que tenemos nuestro carbón
y también hemos formado hidrógeno
gaseoso si éste hidruro toma un protón
formaremos h 2
resaltemos los electrones estos
electrones en rojo tomaron un protón y
formaron este enlace de nuestro
hidrógeno gaseoso que al burbujear
saldrá de la solución así que la
reacción tiene completamente hacia la
derecha así formaremos nuestro avión
enola pto
en el siguiente vídeo hablaremos sobre
otra base llamada l de a que también nos
puede ayudar a obtener el avión enola
pto
completamente